a shinobi whose young master and the man
who separates them this is how sukira
beginners so you're awake
looks like death is not your fate just
yet
the old man speaking is named bushi who
is a hermit in an abandoned temple while
the player-character was unconscious the
teaser trailer for shadows died twice
took place and mushi fashioned for us a
new limb this prosthetic arm is called a
ninja shoe or as the hermit puts it the
perfect fangs for a one-armed wolf
you'll learn to appreciate its worth
and so we're actively named circuito the
wolf who is one half of a pair it's
really clever wordplay as the missing
half of a pair could be referring to the
arm we lost but it could also be
referring to the young Lord that was
taken from us in the beginning in both
senses of the word we plays a character
who is defined by his missing half so I
felt it's only fitting that we split
this video into just like the name
sukira one video for the story of our
missing Lord and one video for the
gameplay implications of a prosthetic
arm because this arm can be fitted with
many different attachments and we know
of five so far
so first the axe it's thrown into our
own hand here to crush the guards of
shield-bearing enemies you know just
like in Dark Souls 3 leaving them open
to a critical strike but our second
attachment the one after this is far
more innovative it's a grappling hook
and if I had to guess I bet we lock on
to available roofs and ledges with our
three you know just like we lock on to
enemies because later in the trailer we
see the character lock onto an enemy and
do a grappling hook attack onto them as
well
so as game-changing as it is to
grappling hook an enemy and dash onto
them it has even more implications when
you think about level design because it
opens up this level of verticality to
the maps that we've literally never
experienced in souls before it's gonna
be so sick because when you think about
it souls is really limited by ladders
and fall damage but in the time it takes
you to climb a ladder in Dark Souls you
would have already scaled that height in
cicchitto and had extra time left over
to leap off of the ledge ambushing an
enemy far below all in the blink of an
eye
so just really huge gameplay
implications there but moving on the
third attachment has us swiftly unsheath
a steel conical hat as a sort of
emergency temporary shield this implies
that some attacks can't be deflected
with our sword and we'll talk a little
bit about that later but the fourth
attachment you might have missed you see
it when our character scatters small
fireworks before the horse
startling it a better angle of this move
is actually seen in this screenshot here
well you can actually see the
firecracker blinding an enemy and
finally the fifth attachment it's not
actually seen in the trailer but I doubt
anyone's gonna be surprised by what this
cannon attachment does it reminds me a
lot of guts as hand cannon arm from
berserk actually and thinking about this
prosthetic arm it is good to know that
they're still going strong with their
berserk inspiration so if it isn't
blatantly obvious already cicchitto is
clearly souls like it's surely the game
that miyazaki said would comply with the
expectations of fans in a
straightforward manner it has all the
tell-tale signs it's got a nameless
protagonist for character customization
it has an emphasis on difficulty that
kills you and it also has combat that's
been tweaked it's just enough to make it
distinct from other titles and I think I
figured out what makes it largely
distinct from Souls and blood-borne
although I could be wrong but I think
about blood-borne for example what's at
the core of its combat it's the insanely
quick - ability and what about Dark
Souls well at the core of its combat for
most players is the fact that its
shields can block the majority of damage
and then look at cicchitto the - is
certainly slower than in blood-borne and
samurai were that they were abandoning
the shield meta around that point in
history so what's left is swordplay
deflection counter-attacks and the
concept of giving no ground to your
opponent the trailer has tons of
examples of this and I've actually never
seen a souls borne gameplay trailer with
so much parrying which to me is evidence
that we're going to be experiencing a
sort of swordplay that is on a higher
level than in previous titles and it's
really likely I think that the swordplay
is enhanced with the ability to use
specific attack moves almost as if you
would use a spell or a weapon art in
Dark Souls so we'll talk a bit more
about that now
notice how the players sword glints in
certain moments and have you noticed
that read ancient Japanese text seen
here and off to the side here as well so
it's totally up for debate what these
mean but I feel like they indicate that
our character might have access to
special abilities skills and attacks
some of which might only be possible by
a successful deflection or two because
he only ever uses them after he deflects
an attack twice and the opponent's we
face are just as capable of this as we
are
notice how the opponent's sword glints
right before he attempts this this
double handed dive attack onto the
player and this attack is coupled with a
red symbol which you can see is
generated from his character not ours so
it's difficult to identify what this
character says but the symbol seems to
serve as a visual warning and it looks a
lot like an ancient Japanese symbol for
danger and it could be wrong but I
believe that it's an alert to sort of
help you in fast-paced combat to assist
you in recognizing when you're about to
be hit by a special attack and these
attacks might have to be blocked with
this special hat shield or dodged as the
same symbol appears here in the fight
with the horseman and the player dodges
it there in response for those with a
keen eye you would have noticed that
another one of these symbols actually
goes off in the trailer when the player
is resurrected it seems that he really
does have to die twice and it's almost
as if this passive resurrection ability
is activating along with this symbol in
this situation what I'm pretty sure is
going down is the enemy believes that
cicchitto is dead and sukira the
one-armed wolf capitalizes on this
running really low and stealthy behind
the giant finishing him off with what
seems to be a back
to attack and it's easy to look past
this but look at the way that he's
running here and here as well look at
him crouching below these floorboards
and skirting this wall to avoid
detection
to me it seems clear that there is a
stealth ability in the game so this
absolutely fits in with the ninja flavor
of the game and just think about it if
you had some sort of way of looking
around corners this could enable amazing
stealth gameplay one of the tag lines of
the game is killed ingeniously so he's
hoping they let us I mean this guy
definitely has his strategy sorted I
guess that's one way to apply pine resin
actually a few Chinese historical dramas
have depicted their executioner's
coating their blade like this before a
kill although it's difficult to identify
exactly why they do this so it's at this
point we definitely need to address a
few leaks that dropped a few weeks ago
before this game was even revealed as
cicchitto at e3 a lot of what leaked
actually ended up being in this trailer
mainly the interaction between the main
character and the Hermit who gives him a
new arm so the fact that the leaks got
this right obviously lends credence to
the rest of what they go on to say for
example before we talked about abilities
and I talked about them a bit more
confidently because the league suggested
that the diverse abilities existed in
the game outside of just traditional
weapon movesets
the league also suggested that the game
mostly takes place in rural locations
which seems to be the case from the
trailer but it also suggested that there
is a larger city to explore as well one
question I have how are we supposed to
travel between cities please tell me
that we can travel and fight on
horseback and while people are currently
freaking out that the game won't be
multiplayer at all the leek suggests
that the game will at least have a
unique PvP system where you sort of
enter the world of someone else under
the guise of an enemy and you take
control of that enemy within the level
with enhanced abilities so from the
enemies we've seen that
be this samurai the horseman or even the
huge murakumo wielder I could see that
happening from memory this was also
supposed to be a mechanic in blood-borne
where you invaded other people's worlds
as a more traditional beast but it was
scrapped cicchitto also supposedly
features a day-and-night / dynamic
weather system which was itself supposed
to make it into Dark Souls 3 and to this
day there's still code in Dark Souls 3
that shows evidence of a day and night
cycle one can only hope that with sukira
shadows die twice they get to deliver
the full brunt of their ambitions with
this game and this is kind of the
perfect time to talk about it
the elephant in the room and the company
that will allow them to maybe fulfill
all of their ambitions activision sukira
shadows die twice is published by
activision not Namco Bandai or Sony as
before I don't think anyone saw this
coming my first thought when saying this
was relief absolute relief first because
this meant shadows died twice wasn't
going to be a ps4 exclusive title as
expected which is great because console
exclusives suck they're really bad for
consumers they pointlessly limit the
amount of people who can enjoy these
amazing games and not to mention being
able to have this game on PC does
wonders for the YouTube community for me
for example it allows me to make better
looking videos it allows me to make them
faster with amazing camera angles and
way more creativity I was also relieved
because publishing through Activision
meant that this game was a new IP and
from thrives with new IPs everyone knows
that look at Demon Souls and Dark Souls
1 and blood-borne the universe that from
software crafts in the first episode of
a franchise is always more exciting than
their attempts to sort of build on
existing stories and inevitably recycle
elements of them so if From Software is
happy with the amount of money that
Activision is throwing at their project
then I'm happy with the
- I mean it will be really really wary
of any hint of casualization or
monetization going forward but I
seriously doubt that from would
compromise on those values now of all
times because think about it from
software is quoting at least three
publishers here they are quoting Namco
they're quoting Activision they're
quoting Sony and games under Miyazaki
have delivered time and time again so if
you're a developer in a position to
court three publishers for the best deal
there's a pretty good chance they got
the best deal so good for them I guess
now I kind of just want to know if
they'll put it on the Blizzard launcher
so to sum up what don't we know about
the gameplay we don't know what the
in-game currency is considering there's
no souls or blood echoes and I have no
clue what's going to be used as a
checkpoint marker without bonfires or a
dream we don't know how to invest in
every one character or level up nor do
we know how exactly cicchitto keeps
coming back to life in fact I wouldn't
be surprised if they rethought the
entire death mechanic a little bit the
way he comes to life mid combat made me
wonder if you could design souls without
checkpoints or true death just the
ability to keep on getting up somehow
and persist anyway what we do know is
there is a hell of a lot of story
already like seriously there's a lot on
the Japanese website that we've
translated and I'll see you in part 2
for that because it sounds like a
fascinating world and I can't wait to
tell you why so thanks for watching guys
and take it easy